sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas casi tres meses
después de la toma del poder por parte
de los talibanes afganistán se ha
convertido en la peor crisis humanitaria
del mundo y es que 22 8 millones de
personas es decir casi la mitad de la
población de ese país se enfrentan a la
inseguridad alimentaria aguda a partir
de este mes de noviembre según el
programa mundial de alimentos y según la
agencia de naciones unidas que lucha
contra el hambre 32 millones de niños
están amenazados por la malnutrición
severa y las necesidades aumentan a
medida que se acerca el invierno el
siguiente es un reportaje de sol en sal
confío en ti sos abuela y sonia que se
lee
kabul como el resto del país se está
hundiendo en la pobreza en este
campamento improvisado cuatro niños
murieron de inanición la semana pasada
la escasa distribución de alimentos por
parte de voluntarios a menudo termina en
violencia
las familias con hombres pueden ir y
conseguir comida pero las familias de
mujeres como la mía no podemos luchar
así que pasamos hambre hace tres meses
cerca de 200 familias desplazadas por el
conflicto encontraron refugio en este
terreno baldío desde entonces han estado
luchando para alimentarse
tuvimos tres vasos de arroz servido para
el almuerzo hoy eso es todo ayer solo
tuvimos pan con té algunos días apenas
tenemos eso y otros días la gente nos da
un kilo de arroz aquí y allá
esta mañana mi hijo me pidió dinero para
comprar algo de pan porque tenía hambre
le dije que esperara hasta que llegara
mi esposo tenía demasiada hambre para
esperar así que le pedí a nuestros
vecinos de la carpa de al lado cuando
llegó mi esposo no tenía dinero así que
no comimos casi un tercio de la
población ya está enfrentando
inseguridad alimentaria en los mercados
los puestos todavía están surtidos pero
los clientes son escasos la crisis
económica junto con la sequía del
invierno han impulsado el alza de los
precios
las papas que acabo de comprar son muy
costosas los precios han subido el doble
todo está aumentando y no hay trabajo
para nosotros
desde que los talibanes se apoderaron
del país la ayuda internacional para el
desarrollo ha quedado bloqueada el nuevo
gobierno inició un programa llamado
comida por trabajo en las ciudades más
grandes del país incluyendo kabul a
cambio de trabajo en nuestra
municipalidad repartirá kilos de trigo
este invierno a los hombres capaces de
hacer trabajo físico hemos identificado
de 2.500 a 3.000 personas en kabul con
la nieve y la lluvia tan cerca los
sistemas de desagüe van a necesitar
mucho mantenimiento
según la onu nueve de cada diez familias
afganas no tendrán suficiente comida en
los meses por venir una crisis
alimentaria que solo ha empeorado desde
el retorno de los talibanes
[Música]
el ministro del interior francés legal
de la mano lo calificó como un modelo
europeo hablamos del nuevo campamento
para solicitantes de asilo de la isla
griega de samos que ofrece mejores
condiciones de vida y de seguridad para
quienes intentan buscar nuevas
posibilidades en europa y es que este
centro abrió sus puertas justamente en
momentos en los que grecia se enfrenta a
la posibilidad de una nueva oleada
migratoria a consecuencia de la toma del
poder por parte de los talibanes en
afganistán y este es un informe de
natalie históricas y alexia que falaz
este es el día de la vacunación contra
el cob y 19 para los residentes de este
campamento de asilo en samos justo
después del trabajo regresan a sus
actividades tiene capacidad para 3.000
solicitantes de asilo y cuenta con wifi
un centro deportivo y un parque infantil
pero con alambre de púas puertas de
seguridad y escáneres de rayos x este
campamento en el noroeste de samos está
ubicado en una zona desierta y está
segregado del resto de la isla los 360
solicitantes de asilo que actualmente
viven allí se dividen por origen en
recipientes de diferentes colores las
autoridades griegas continúan
respaldando las medidas de seguridad
reforzadas a pesar de las fuertes
críticas
la seguridad es fundamental para
nuestros residentes porque afirman haber
abandonado sus países por razones de
seguridad
europea grecia está en la frontera entre
europa y asia o él está en general por
lo que el papel es proteger las
fronteras europeas ética o firmé una
pruebas por su venta de ropa de casino y
eso no es todo el campamento de 43
millones de euros financiado por la
unión europea está equipado con un
sistema de vigilancia único las cámaras
están directamente vinculadas al
ministerio de migración en atenas
alice llegó hace menos de tres semanas
desde sierra leona el peligroso viaje a
través de irán la dejo con profundas
heridas que están luchando por sanar yo
me metieron en una casa grande y venían
hombres a violarme cuando decidí escapar
conocí a la gente y los seguir por el
bosque caminaba de noche en las montañas
estaba exhausta y no tenía nada para
comer
me daban comida sólo para violarme
quiero quedarme ingresé porque me siento
bien
for me
las autoridades esperan dar la
bienvenida a los migrantes que
sobrevivieron a los mares griegos con
otros campamentos que se inaugurarán
próximamente
durante mucho tiempo los reporteros han
sido víctimas tanto de gobiernos
autoritarios como de grupos armados y
desafortunadamente esa tendencia sigue
al alza según la ong reporteros sin
fronteras tan solo en lo que va del año
35 miembros de la prensa han sido
asesinados y casi 350 de ellos se
encuentran encarcelados en diferentes
partes del mundo el siguiente es un
reportaje de que te van gogh ya están y
fanny a la imaginado
hace siete años sin fold y se convirtió
en el primer periodista estadounidense
en ser ejecutado por el grupo estado
islámico su decapitación filmada y su
vida en línea conmocionó al mundo para
la madre de folk y jim murió por los
valores que apreciaba
quién murió por lo que pensó que era la
verdad por lo que sintió que era
importante sintió que era un trabajo que
debía hacerse estaba soltero sentía que
podía hacerlo le encantó le encantó
escuchar lo que estaba pasando y luego
escribir la historia capturando las
imágenes para traer de vuelta al mundo
michaels
tres semanas después de la muerte de jim
ryan foley creó una fundación pidiendo
al gobierno de eeuu que hiciera más para
liberar a los rehenes reporteros o no
cada vez es más peligroso ser periodista
ya sea en este país o en todo el mundo y
creo que esto se debe principalmente a
que hay mucha desinformación ahora que
hace más difícil que la verdad salga a
la luz
a menos que se responsabiliza a las
personas que atacan matan y torturan a
los periodistas
de la isla al arian ha convertido en una
prioridad proteger a sus reporteros
después de 20 años de informar en
entornos hostiles ahora es ella quien
envía a los periodistas a los sitios de
peligro con protocolos de seguridad y
tratamos de averiguar todo lo posible
sobre el sitio al que vamos en lugar de
simplemente lanzarnos en paracaídas y no
darnos cuenta atacados encarcelados o
asesinados la violencia en contra de los
periodistas ha aumentado en todo el
mundo en los últimos 30 años más de 1400
han sido asesinados y los perpetradores
rara vez comparecen ante la justicia
y regresamos a la región del sáhara
occidental' allí activistas y
periodistas que viven bajo la ocupación
marroquí son víctimas de maltratos
arrestos torturas y desapariciones por
el simple hecho de ser saharauis que
defienden sus derechos y esta es una
situación que se ha recrudecido desde la
ruptura del alto el fuego el 13 de
noviembre de 2020 el siguiente es un
informe de tell bonet y diego ibarra
ha pasado un año desde c's sultana jaya
fue legalmente confinada por las
autorías marroquíes en su domicilio por
defender los derechos de los saharauis
le golpearon el ojo con una piedra en el
aire
y
sidi ali nos explica que sultán ha sido
física y sexualmente agredida por
hombres encapuchados y repetidamente
amenazada de muerte se abandonaba su
vivienda
y actualmente está sin electricidad sin
comunicaciones que incluye internet y le
prohibieron todas las visitas todo esto
es poco con lo que está sufriendo
sultana cautiva en su propia casa
el
crimen
pero el caso de sultana no es aislado
este joven periodista pasó los últimos
cuatro años de su vida en cárceles
marroquíes por denunciar los abusos
contra los saharauis en los territorios
ocupados ahora vive en los campamentos
de tindúf lejos de su familia y teme
regresar
he sido encarcelado y torturado también
han amenazado a mi familia muchas veces
tuve que huir porque tenía por mi vida
pero no vamos a rendirnos seguiremos
luchando por la causa saharaui
mohamed es del programa de la serie de
activistas saharauis ha aumentado tras
el cese del alto el fuego en los
territorios ocupados de los defensores
de derechos humanos como abdelsalam
denuncian que estas violaciones ya se
venían haciendo durante los periodos de
paz número de detenidos desaparecidos no
no para de crecer tenemos un total de
30.000 de distensiones arbitrarios a lo
largo de estos años más de 4500 casos de
tres a presiones aún cuando se agrava la
violación de los derechos humanos en el
sáhara occidental ni el arresto ni las
agresiones físicas han logrado apagar
las voces y de otros activistas
retenidos presentes en cada rincón de
los campamentos saharauis
y tras 20 meses eeuu finalmente abrió
sus fronteras aéreas a los países
europeos unas medidas de cierre que
habían sido implementadas por donald
trump y que se mantuvieron en vigor
durante la primera parte del gobierno de
joe biden ahora será necesario dar
muestra de un esquema de vacunación
completo y tener a la mano una prueba
pcr negativo para ingresar al país sin
embargo esto es un verdadero alivio para
miles de personas que estuvieron
separadas de sus seres queridos desde
marzo de 2020 y nuestro equipo en
washington fue al encuentro de un
expatriado francés a punto de reunirse
nuevamente con su familia el siguiente
es un informe de que de vanguardia están
y fanny a la imaginado
y en él hay sembrar vive y trabaja en
eeuu desde 2015 el ciudadano francés no
ha estado en francia en casi dos años y
se le prohibió hacer el viaje de regreso
a eeuu después de escuchar que se
levantaría la prohibición de viajar
inmediatamente reservó un vuelo a casa
quiero ver a todas las personas que no
he visto en mucho tiempo pero también he
cambiado mucho durante estos dos años
descubrí así que estoy deseando poder
hablar con mi familia verlos y
divertirnos
un poco
desde su último viaje a francia su
familia ha crecido ahora tiene dos
sobrinos y una sobrina que no ha
conocido en persona la separación ha
sido dura para eisenberg a pesar de
estar en contacto diario con su familia
su padre dice que si bien la tecnología
los ayudo a mantenerse en contacto
también tenía sus límites
[Música]
lo que veía más difícil es no tener
estas interacciones grupales donde él
puede intervenir cuando estamos 5 o 6
personas alrededor de la mesa hablando
no podemos permitirle que participe de
una manera real
counting the hours su contenido mismo
es un gran alivio hablar por videochat
sabiendo que la próxima vez hablaremos
en persona para recuperar el tiempo
perdido aysén ver planea quedarse en
francia dos meses y llevará muchos
regalos
son sábanas que mi mamá no pudo
encontrar un teclado ergonómico que
quería mi hermano
tengo muchos juguetes pequeños y también
medicinas que no encuentras en francia-
para mis padres
al igual que aizenberg decenas de
familias y amigos están a punto de
reunirse en el extranjero o en eeuu los
viajeros extranjeros sea cual sea su
país de origen ahora pueden volar a los
eeuu siempre y cuando muestren un
comprobante de vacunación y una prueba
de kobin negativa
gracias por acompañarnos en esta nueva
emisión de corresponsables nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom